hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
this problem caused a lot of controversy
online
could you do the sats question that made
pupils cry
this problem was given to year 6
students in england who were aged 11
years old
in the following diagram
make two straight line cuts along the
grid lines which divide the rectangle
into three shapes
you want two squares of different sizes
and one rectangle
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
you might get started by making two cuts
in this grid
but you'll notice it divides the
rectangle into four shapes and two cuts
usually make four shapes
so this caused a lot of confusion
how are you supposed to make two cuts
which only result in three shapes
well you have to be a little creative
and as i like to say you have to think
inside the box
what if you made one cut after the other
cut
to get started notice that there are
five squares here
so let's make our first cut so that we
have a five by five square
we'll make the cut here
now we'll separate this shape so we have
one shape which is a five by five square
and now we'll make the remaining cut
along this following rectangle
this is two squares wide so we'll make
the cut here to create a two by two
square
we've now created a total of three
shapes and this solves the problem
we've created two squares of different
sizes and we have a rectangle left
over it's a pretty tricky problem to see
on a test with time pressure
but i think is a pretty neat problem
because you have to think a little bit
creatively
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you